bom eu gostaria de propor a voz
de imaginação que vocês acompanharem
comigo esse é um exercício
imagine se de repente fosse divulgada a
descoberta de um artefato orbitando em
um ponto muito distantes no universo da
terra um ponto do qual seria impossível
avançar com os instrumentos tecnológicos
que permitem ao ser humano o
conhecimento científico na trilogia de
cinco livros um mochileiro das galáxias
o escritor douglas adams imaginou que no
fim do universo haveria um restaurante
bom mas vamos imaginar que ao invés de
um estabelecimento comercial
o artefato descoberta no fim do universo
fosse um banheiro químico
um desses azuis que a gente costuma
encontrar em grandes eventos como esses
que estavam espalhados pelas cidades
brasileiras durante o carnaval quais
poderiam ser as consequências da
divulgação de uma descoberta como essa
boa notícia seria transmitida por todos
os meios midiáticos compartilhada por
milhões de pessoas pelas redes sociais
ao redor do planeta
então acho que a primeira consequência
importante seria a proliferação de memes
sobre o banheiro químico do fim do
universo
o meme é um dispositivo que nos ajude a
mediar uma realidade que atingiu seu
grau máximo de absurdo
outra consequência eu acho que seria
banheiro otimização da cultura
o banheiro químico do fim do universo se
tornaria onipresente uma infinidade de
produtos seria criada reproduzido a
forma a cor e por que não talvez até o
conteúdo do banheiro químico do fim do
universo
o banheiro químico iria aparecer em
roupas games aplicativos brinquedos
geladeira na forma de ver químico capas
para celulares bares temáticos perfumes
imagine um produto ou um serviço que
você gosta muito e pense como ele
poderia se adaptar à nova era do
banheiro químico
é evidente que a indústria do banheiro
químico seria aquecida a demanda
aumentar ia assim como custo final do
produto para os consumidores
talvez um banheiro químico virasse uma
moda entre a classe média tipo cerveja
artesanal ou barbearia
obviamente a arte também
ampliaria a descoberta e é muito
provável que a ciência também foi
impactado por ela
será que as disciplinas científicas
disponíveis hoje dariam conta de estudar
esse artefato ou será que a gente
precisaria criar novas áreas da ciência
uma probabilidade é que as descobertas
astronômicas sinalizar a existência de
vida inteligente extraterrestre mas já
que a princípio seria impossível para o
ser humano tende a coisa tão distante
caso a inteligência a existência de vida
inteligente fosse comprovada e ela
estivesse viva como se chamaria
antropologia do e te esse outro absoluto
um outro está além do outro
é certo que os ets poderiam se chamando
a ciência deles que nos estudasse de
antropologia e se de alguma maneira o
artefato tivesse sido enviado pelo homem
arqueologia estudo das civilizações do
passado através da escavação de
vestígios materiais mas nesse caso o
artefato não estaria na terra então
daria para continuar chamando de
arqueologia e outro isso o banheiro
tivesse sido enviado por uma civilização
que ainda não existe como chamaria
arqueologia dos artefatos do futuro
havia também muita especulação sobre a
finalidade do banheiro químico sua
ontologia e se ele fosse uma máquina do
espaço-tempo como a cabine de telefone
tardes do seriado de tv doctor who ou se
ele fosse uma entidade inteligente
perigosa como um monolito de 2001 ele
poderia também ser uma obra de arte ou
quem sabe um dispositivo litúrgico como
confessionário da igreja católica
evidente também que ele poderia ser
apenas um banheiro químico como qualquer
outro
imagine também que a divulgação dessa
notícia poderia trazer mudanças na
percepção sobre o nosso lugar no
universo e também de nosso lugar dentro
da própria sociedade
o anúncio da descoberta talvez fizesse
compreender um pouco mais sobre a nossa
efemeridade diante da eternidade do
universo e sobre a nossa insignificância
em relação à vastidão infinita do cosmos
existe uma longa tradição narrativa que
começa na bíblia e chega até hollywood
já poder o bastante
questões como essa o milenarista surgiu
na idade média a partir de
interpretações do livro das revelações
contidas no novo testamento
essa doutrina religiosa integra se chama
de escatologia cristã
além de ter um sentido que a gente
normalmente associa essa palavra que
aquele que define o interesse por fezes
ou obscuridades a escatologia uma parte
da teologia que imagina os últimos
eventos do homem ea história do mundo a
escatologia cristã trata do apocalipse
sob essa perspectiva o banheiro químico
do fim do universo seria um artefato
duplamente escatológico milenaristas
refere a segunda vinda de cristo o reino
do céu na terra que duraria mil anos as
características principais do
milenaristas são 1 ele é coletivo a
salvação é pra todos
2 ele é terrestre a salvação se dá na
própria terra e não no além
3 ele é iminente a salvação pode
acontecer a qualquer minuto 4 ele é
total a salvação vai transformar
completamente o mundo 5 ele é
sobrenatural são forças externas que
provocaram a salvação terrena como
discurso e prática milenarista está no
ponto oposto da utopia autopia que
imaginar um mundo que ainda não tem
lugar nesse plano mas que ainda poderá
existir um dia e quando isso acontecer
conforme o tom pistas acreditam todos
seremos felizes
já os milenares imagino que o mundo vai
acabar a qualquer momento
portanto não há tempo para ficar
sonhando com uma nova sociedade que um
dia talvez seja perfeita
o milenar está agindo agora ele quer
transformar a sociedade sem perder tempo
de forma radical
através da inversão dos valores morais e
da destruição total da ordem das coisas
ideias milenares tiveram grande
influência através dos séculos e não só
e movimentos religiosos mas também em
movimentos políticos sociais e culturais
alguns exemplos de milenarista através
dos tempos
as profecias de nostradamus as idéias de
antônio conselheiro que levaram à
insurreição arraial de canudos
é um massacre dos insurgentes pelo
governo republicano a religião
jamaicanas rastafáris com sua
interpretação do novo testamento chamada
arrastou elogia também existe um longo
debate se marcos teria pertencido a essa
corrente ou não já que ele era muito
crítico ao socialismo utópico na década
de 50 o historiador norman com publicou
um estudo sobre seitas milenares chamado
depois city of the millennium com
definiu esse ser é giz medievais como
anarquistas místicos
a exemplo da irmandade do espírito livre
que na europa dos séculos 13 e 14
dentre outras heresias defende a busca
do prazer sexual como forma de se
aproximar de deus essas idéias acabaram
ganhando muito eco na contracultura dos
anos 60 é sabido que demore os
situacionistas foram bastante
influenciados pelas idéias do livro de
cone
a gente está vendo que de bora michel
bertin e o asg de ordem
eu gosto de pensar que as considerações
da feminista radical valeri solanas a
respeito de uma sociedade sem homens têm
um fundo milenar está além do punk com
seu lema não filtro bom então imagine
agora que diante da descoberta desse
artefato surgisse uma espécie de
milenarista 2.0 uma reação escatológica
a descoberta de um artefato escatológico
bom a proliferação de seitas e
movimentos políticos culturais sociais
técnicos que começasse a propor de forma
radical pela ação a transformação total
da sociedade
agora imaginem se de repente começasse a
circular uma outra notícia a descoberta
do banheiro químico do fim do universo
não passava de uma pós verdade o
banheiro jamais existiu foi apenas uma
ação publicitária promovida por uma
grande corporação com interesse na
colonização espacial e no fomento da
indústria do banheiro químico
o paradoxo de ferm se refere à falta de
evidências sobre a existência de vida
inteligente extraterrestre sendo um
universo infinito o sistema solar apenas
um dos sistemas entre infinito
os temas ea terra uma forma geológico
poderia se repetir em outro ponto do
espaço sideral porque ainda há gente não
fez contato com vida inteligente
uma das respostas para esse paradoxo é
que há vida inteligente tende a sua
própria destruição
obrigado
[Aplausos]